so this is going to be an insanely deep
dive into your filmography for my first
question it is a role I think of often
and a show that I recommend to people
all the time but what was it like
filming Frankenstein's Wedding live in
Leeds
wow Maggie you've gone deep
uh that was that was incredible yeah I
mean I mean I was I was a year out of
drama school
um it was live we'd um we'd rehearsed
once with the band I had to sing live I
had to dance live I had to get married
live
um it was in Leeds we had a live
audience of 12 000 people so it as as a
baptism baptism of fire or somebody who
just left drama school it's the thing
that I constantly remind myself saying
if I can do that I can do anything yeah
well you really did well it was I
watched it when it first aired all those
years ago and it was such a fantastic
performance more shows should uh perform
in crumbling Abbeys you know what I
couldn't I couldn't agree more I think
yeah the BBC was so it was so brave
doing that project and um it was yeah it
was a unique project definitely
definitely definitely jumping into
Carnival row I'm so sad that it's ending
but glad that things got to wrap up did
your approach to Ezra change at all
between the seasons
definitely yeah definitely did
um season one for me was almost
I I had this etiquette book so I had
like a Victorian etiquette book from uh
like the 1800s which was an original
book written by a Victorian gentleman of
how to live the society and I did that
was my Bible for the whole whole of the
Season that was that was it
um that Bible in season two went
completely out of the window having read
the scripts because basically you know
you think how your character is going to
be tested and then Eric Olson tested my
character in in ways that was unexpected
for the audience it would be so
unexpected and for me as the first time
I read it it was it was so unexpected so
I think yeah season two The Challenge
was kind of dealing with even though
Ezra is an anti-hero dealing with him is
is the hero of his own piece and why he
needs his sister so much back in his
life how he's going to do it and and I
guess when he's put in these scenarios
what parts of Ezra he uses and that was
you know not to spoil any anything but
definitely the animalistic side of Ezra
as a human death definitely comes out in
in season two
definitely I I know I was rooting for
him to maybe like have a turn which you
know things that I was hoping I was
hoping um but where do you think he
reached that point of like there was no
return for him like he was determined
that he was going to get his sister back
into his life
I mean there's there's definitely so
there's definitely a point in season two
where there's a point of no return
um and it's so interesting because the
burgish society is as you see
um a lot of it is based on the Victorian
society it's all about reputation and
there's there's two big points at the
beginning of season season two where
things kind of pardon the pun but stab
him and in the back and make him feel
like his name is disgraced and there's
no way back for them
um so there's but but there's definitely
a point I think it's episode three for
Ezra where I I think that's where he he
reaches a point of himself that he he I
don't think he he ever thought was
capable of
um but then it's interesting to then see
how that he deals with that going going
forward
um because I think he covers it again
quite well
um or tries to in his own way what was
the most difficult film to see the two
uh film for the season I think I mean
night shoots are always interesting to
shoot because your deal you know you're
dealing with um a different sort of
Spider Sense of like
big big emotional scenes to shoot at
night time are always quite difficult
especially when it's winter in Prague it
gets very cold
um so a couple of those scenes out on
the back lot were quite were quite
challenging
um in the in in the night time but you
know again because we're surrounded by
such Geniuses on set such like artistic
Geniuses from makeup had
um the actors that I got to work with it
it was it was all joyous but those were
those are the ones that stick out just
for the temperature I did want to ask
about another project that you're
working on I think you just wrapped on
the winter King yes which is based on
such a phenomenal book uh series but how
would you compare your role in that to
some of your previous roles oh the
winter King
uh again just totally different totally
different context it's medieval it's a
retelling of the legend of Arthur
um and again you know I just get to the
Joy when I when I I'm offered things or
when scripts come into my inbox I'm
always looking for something I haven't
played because that's I don't want to
play the same thing I don't want to play
the same time period and I'm just lucky
that um those franchisor books they
they've offered me a character Sansom
who I play that that goes on a you know
a mad journey in in his own way but in
in a totally different way so it's um
yeah just lucky to land another
character that I can hopefully bring
life to on the screen it was fun I just
interviewed at Delirious yesterday for
you and I watched the screeners of you
and I saw you pop up in that and I was
like oh I have to ask what was it like
getting to join that franchise for a
little bit do you know what it is the
first modern job I've done for a long
time with my own with my own hair and my
own um beard and
um I got to wear modern clothing uh but
great incredible to incredible to work
with um with the cast there and and
shooting in London which I know is a big
thing for you filming in London because
it's it's you know that's a first so it
was nice to uh yeah to meet the to meet
the cast in such a popular show and
can't wait for can't wait to see it
myself because I haven't seen any of it
so it'll be fantastic to see well there
you go well thank you so much for your
time today Andrew I really appreciate it
pleasure Maggie thank you so so much